So we saw in the last video
why if you represent scheduling
constraints among
courses by a digraph
that it's critical that that
digraph in fact be a DAG.
And let's now look at this
scheduling issue represented
by DAGs in more detail.
So here's a chart of a selection
of Course 6 prerequisites--
some of them obsolete, but
they serve the purposes
of being an
illustrative example--
and the little arrows
here are indicating
arrows in the digraph.
So what this tells
me is that 18.01
is listed as an
immediate prerequisite
in the catalog for 6.042.
18.01 is also an immediate
prerequisite of 18.02.
6.001 and 6.004 are both
prerequisites of 6.033,
and 6.042 of 6.046,
and 6.046 of 6.840.
So we're seeing here this
indirect prerequisite issue
that I mentioned before, which
is that even though the only
thing listed as a prerequisite
for 6.840 in the catalog is
6.046, as a matter of fact in
order to take 6.046 you have
to have taken 6.042.
So 6.042 is an indirect
prerequisite of 6.840.
So in terms of graph
language and path language,
a subject u is an
indirect prerequisite of v
when there's is
a positive length
path from u to v
in the digraph that
describes the prerequisite
structure among the classes.
It simply means that-- using
our notation for R plus
is the positive
length path relation
of a digraph or a
binary relation R--
it simply means
u R plus v, which
is read as there is a positive
length path from u to v.
Now, a key idea that we're
going to be examining
in learning how to
do scheduling is
the idea of a minimal subject.
So the definition
of a minimal subject
is a subject that
has no prerequisites,
no arrows in, a
freshman subject.
So nothing comes in.
There are three
examples of subjects
with no prerequisites
in the preceding chart,
namely 18.01, 8.02, and 6.001.
Let me say a word about where
this funny terminology minimal
comes from.
It's because another
way to talk about DAGs
is in terms of things that are
like order relations called
partial orders, which we'll
be looking at shortly.
And so you think of
the later subjects
as being bigger than
the earlier subjects.
So a minimal
subject is one where
there is nothing less than it.
Now, there might be
several minimal subjects,
because it might be
that neither one of them
is less than the other,
but there's nothing
less than 18.01.
There's no other subject that
you have to take before 18.01.
So that's the
definition of minimal.
Nothing smaller.
Now, you could ask
what's a minimum, which
you may be more familiar with.
A minimum means that not only
is there nothing before it,
but it comes before
everything else.
It would be the earliest
of all possible subjects
in the indirect
prerequisite chain.
There isn't any in this
example, but there actually
used to be one at MIT.
For a while, we experimented
with giving an orientation week
summer assignment, that is,
an assignment over the summer
for newly admitted
students in order for them
to take a subject
during orientation
week in which they discussed
some book that they had all
been assigned to
read beforehand.
Seemed like a great idea to kind
of pull the freshman community
together, but it turned
out to be unsustainable
because they couldn't
find enough faculty
and others willing to
conduct these seminars.
So MIT stopped having
a minimum subject.
So let's look at
the prerequisites
again, and discuss how
to do a scheduling.
And the first thing we're
going to do in the schedule
is, as I say, identify
the minimal elements.
There are the three of
them that we mentioned.
And we're going to start
by deciding that we'll take
those three in the first term.
So we're going to be operating
with basically what's
called a greedy strategy.
We're going to
take as many things
as we possibly can take at any
term given the constraints.
So we can take all the freshman
subjects in our first term
because they have
no prerequisites.
Well, the next step, then,
is just get rid of them
because they're
scheduled already.
So we can get rid of all those
occurrences of 18.01, 8.02,
and 6.001, not only-- there are
other occurrences as well here
where 18.01 is a
prerequisite for things.
So they're all gone, and
we get a simplified diagram
where we've removed
the minimal elements.
Now in the new
diagram, there are now
things that didn't
used to be minimal
before but are minimal now.
These are the new
minimal elements,
and we can identify those.
Here are five subjects--
four here and one there--
that now have no
more prerequisites.
These are kind of the second
level minimal elements,
and we're going to
schedule them next.
So those are all the
subjects that we can possibly
take after we've taken the
first set of minimal subjects.
They're the second
level minimals.
And we'll schedule
them in the next term.
This is our five subject
second term schedule.
Likewise, you delete
these guys, and then you
discover that 6.046 and 6.004
are the resulting minimal ones,
which it's now possible to take
because all their prerequisites
have been satisfied.
So we schedule them in the
third term, 6.840 and 6.033,
by the same reasoning,
in the fourth term,
and 6.857 in the fifth term.
There is our complete
term schedule obtained
in this particular way.
There's, of course, many
other ways to schedule it,
but this is a particular orderly
way where the strategy, again,
is greedy.
You take as many
things as you possibly
can take in a given term.
Now, there are
some concepts that
come up when you're
talking about schedules
that are worth introducing.
So one of them is an antichain.
An antichain is-- in
this particular example
means a set of
subjects where there
are no indirect
prerequisites among them.
They can be taken in any order,
because it doesn't matter
whether you've taken one
or not when you're thinking
about taking the others.
In technical language,
again motivated
by the idea of thinking
of there being a path
as though it was less than
or equal to something,
these are elements
that are incomparable.
Neither one is less than
or equal to another.
So in terms of
the path relation,
u is incomparable
to v if and only
if there is no path from u to v
of positive length and there's
no positive length
path from v to u.
So let's look at some
antichains-- and the part
of the point of
defining it is we
have chosen antichains as
our schedule for each term.
So the freshman subjects
with no prerequisites,
clearly there's no
path among them,
because there is no
path to them at all.
So they are an antichain.
The next level we chose
were the second level
minimal elements, which
only had as prerequisites
the original minimal elements,
and so certainly none of them
was a prerequisite
of the others.
So that's another
example of an antichain.
And of course the third
level and the fourth level
and the fifth level
are antichains.
But not all antichains
are there in our schedule.
So for example here, is a
diagonal lying antichain.
6.840, 6.004, and 6.034
have no paths between them.
So in fact it's possible to
take them simultaneously,
because you could have taken
all their prerequisites
in the upper left here and
then take the three of them.
So that's what an
antichain means here.
So the technical definition
is no path between any two
of them, but in terms of
the scheduling of courses,
it means it's possible to
take them in the same term
if you've satisfied all
their prerequisites,
which it is possible to do.
So let's ask about the
various patterns of scheduling
that are possible.
We've discovered this
particular greedy one,
where we take as many
things as we can each term.
But suppose that I was
constrained to only take
one subject per term.
I was going to-- I
have an outside job,
I'm too busy to take more
than one class a term,
and if MIT will let
me dawdle so long,
that's what I'd like to do.
So can I do this?
Yeah, well sure.
Just schedule all the
minimal elements first
in any order, one, two, three.
And then schedule the five
second level minimal elements
next, and the third
level, and so on.
And it's perfectly
possible, then,
to modify the
schedule that we found
into a schedule in which you
only take one subject per term,
and of course you
only take a subject
after you've taken
all of its indirect
and direct prerequisites.
This is called a
topological sort.
Again, the sorting word
comes from the motivation
of thinking of there being
a path as like a less
than or equal to relation.
So we're sorting things in
order of increasing size.
18.01 would be, in this
case, a smallest element
and 6.857 a biggest in
this list of elements.
A chain is kind of
technically, literally,
a thing called the
dual of an antichain.
A chain is a
sequence of subjects
that must be taken in order.
That is, these are subjects
where for any two of them,
you know which one
has to come first.
That is, between any
two of them there is
a path in one way or the other.
Now of course, it's
a DAG, so there can't
be paths in both directions.
So a chain is simply a set
of comparable elements, which
implies that there's an order
in which they have to be taken.
So here are some chains.
This one was shown pictorially
as a vertical chain
with five courses in it.
Here's a vertical chain of four.
And not all of
them are vertical.
Here's a chain where you have
to take 18.01 before you take
18.03 before you take 6.004.
So they form a chain.
It's important to
realize that this
is a chain with
five subjects in it,
but a chain doesn't have to
have every possible element that
could be in it.
It's still a chain even if it's
only got these three subjects,
because there's a path
from 8.02 to 6.004
and a path from 6.004 to 6.857.
But maximum length
chains, chains
that are as full as possible,
are important theoretically.
And so this in particular
is a maximal length chain.
The longest chain
here is of length 5.
Now, it's not the only one.
There's another chain of length
5 here if you look for it.
But no chain is of
length longer than 5
and there is one of length
5, and that leads us
to the question of how many
terms is it necessarily
going to take to graduate.
Well, we saw that you
can graduate in five.
But given that there's a
maximum chain of length 5,
it means that you
can't do it in fewer,
because those five courses
have to be taken consecutively.
The third has to
be taken in a term
after the first two
have been taken.
The second has to be
taken after the first.
If you have a chain of any
size, actually, the number
of terms to graduate has
to be at least as big
as that chain,
which means it has
to be at least as many terms
as a maximum size chain.
So five terms are
necessary, and we
saw using our minimal
strategy of being
greedy that you can always do
it in maximum chain length.
So five are also sufficient.
This is providing that you
can take an unlimited number
of subjects per term.
Remember our strategy to
graduate in five terms
was to take as many subjects
as we possibly could each term.
So there's the sufficient
way to take subjects
to graduate in five terms.
And of course,
one consequence is
that in my second
term freshman year,
I was taking five subjects
because it was possible.
But that leaves me with a
kind of heavily loaded term
compared to-- here's a
term with two subjects,
and there's a term with only
one subject at the very end.
So it's possible, in fact, to
somewhat adjust the term load.
Let's just shift taking
18.02 to the third term.
It's perfectly
feasible to do that,
because I will have satisfied
all the prerequisites of 18.02
after the first term,
but I don't have
to take it in the second term.
Let's shift it off.
So now I've lightened the
load in the second term
to four subjects,
somewhat increasing
the load-- I had to do it
somewhere-- in the third term
to three subjects.
So now I have to take no more
than four subjects a term.
And as a matter of
fact, if you fiddle,
you can actually find
a graduating schedule
in which you can only take
three subjects per term.
And we will examine what's
the minimum number of subjects
per term in the next segment.